foreign
[Music]
I'm an assistant professor at OHSU I've
just started my lab there my work has
focused on generating T-cell responses
against pancreatic cancer which is what
I'm going to discuss today
so pancreatic cancer is the third
leading cause of cancer-related
mortality in the United States it's
higher than breast cancer and
unfortunately this disease is highly
treatment resistant not just to
common treatments that have been used
for a number of years but also
importantly it's very resistant to
immunotherapy there's a number of
reasons for this and we don't fully
understand the tumor microenvironment
and how to overcome these barriers
the pancreatic tumor microenvironment
has a low average human mutation burden
but it's not zero and there are a fair
number of patients that actually have a
moderate number of T cells that
infiltrate into the tumor site and we do
know that for those patients that have a
higher T Cell infiltration they do have
a higher survival rate so it does
suggest that there should be some
potential to harness the immune response
against this tumor however even patients
that have a high tumor mutation burden
that are MSI High have a very low
response State response rate to immune
checkpoint therapies
um so almost no patients are responding
to immune checkpoint blockade here I'm
just showing patient samples uh in the
tumor microenvironment you can see that
there's a very high cd45 infiltrate into
the tumor site but most of these cells
are usually myeloid cells and for the
majority of patients there's actually a
relatively few T cells in the tumor site
so to understand the barriers to
developing immune responses against this
tumor in the lab we're taking advantage
of the KBC Mouse model these mice have
mutated k-ras and loss of p53
specifically in the pancreas these are
the two mutations most commonly found in
patient samples and you can see here
that if we look at the histology the
tumors in the KPC mice really
recapitulate the tumors in patients so
there's a high cd45 infiltrate into the
tumor site but again most of these cells
are myeloid cells and especially in the
mouse model you can see that there's a
true dearth of T cells in the tumor
microenvironment
we and others have described multiple
mechanisms of immunosuppression in the
pancreatic tumor site including stromal
elements and tumor cell intrinsic
features that really prevent T Cell
infiltration into the tumor and provide
a very strong barrier to immune
responses against this tumor
similar to patients that are the hardest
to treat the KPC Mouse model has a very
low tumor mutation burden there are very
few T cells infiltrating as I'm showing
here and they're highly resistant to
therapeutic attention
here we are just showing some examples
of the therapies that these tumors are
resistant to we use the KBC Mouse model
to generate a tumor cell line that we
could then implant back into wild type
mice and you can see here when we treat
mice with either genocide being alone
not packed with hacksaw alone or the
combination of the two which is a
standard of care for patients with
pancreatic cancer we have no impact on
the tumor growth rate in these mice
similarly if we treat the mice with
checkpoint blockade either anti-pd1
alone anti-ctla4 alone or even the
combination of the two we really cannot
control this primary tumor growth so the
KPC tumors are highly resistant to
standard care chemotherapy and immune
checkpoint blockade modeling again those
patients that that are the hardest to
treat in the clinical setting
so just to orient us to how we're
thinking about generating an immune
response against this tumor I wanted to
start with a tumor immunity cycle
generally you can imagine immune
response against a virus or another
pathogen will have multiple steps along
the path including antigen presentation
T Cell priming infiltration of the T
cells into the target site and then
killing of the target cells by the T
cells
in the tumor immunity cycle we know that
one or more of these steps are broken
somewhere along the path often several
and especially with regard to current
therapies we know that most of the
treatments are focusing on this side of
the effector response against a tumor
there's a presupposition of an existing
T Cell response that needs to be
reinvigorated or rescued an immune
checkpoint blockade has done that very
well in many aggressive tumor models
such as melanoma and longanocarcinoma in
those cases blocking inhibitory
receptors such as anti-pd1 cla4 are now
also tim3 allows for T cells to
infiltrate back into the tumor site or
recover their function within the tumor
site leading to the death of cancer
cells
however we know that in many tumors such
as in pancreatic cancer this is simply
not working and so we need to think
about other ways to generate this T Cell
response against a tumor
our lab has focused on the hypothesis
that priming a T-cell response may
actually overcome the therapeutic
resistance that we're seeing in
pancreatic cancer and many other
aggressive tumor types so we've decided
to focus on the step of antigen
presentation and the priming and
activation of T cells against the tumor
to do this we're taking advantage of the
agonistic cd40 antibody this antibody
mimics the natural cd40 ligand and when
we administer it we have cross-linking
of cd40 on dendritic cells or other
Inogen presenting cells driving the
licensing and maturation of these apcs
as a result we have the generation of a
T Cell response that expands and we've
shown that this T Cell response actually
can traffic into the tumor site mbda
tumor aggression
so we had two key questions that I
wanted to address in this presentation
we first wanted to understand if
therapeutically enhancing T Cell priming
would actually elicit anti-tumor immune
responses against pancreatic cancer and
if that is true we then wanted to
determine what the correlates of
response to immunotherapy were
especially within the tumor
microenvironment
so as I described before we made a cell
line from our KPC mice we could then
implant that cell line back into B6 mice
and here I'm just showing our treatment
schema where we implant our tumors
around two weeks before we begin therapy
waiting until we have an established
tumor at that point we can treat mice as
I showed before with genocidemine and
that Paco taxol standard of care
chemotherapy for patients with
pancreatic cancer
two days later we followed this with a
single dose of agonistic cd40 and then
we monitored these mice for survival
so here I'm showing the survival curves
of mice treated with our combination of
agonistic cd40 and genocide to be in
that paclitaxal shown here in the open
circles and you can see that mice that
received this treatment regimen actually
survived long term compared to mice
treated either with chemotherapy alone
cd40 alone or vehicle controls
we did a number of studies that I'm
summarizing here in this slide to show
that we actually had clonal expansion of
our T cells locally within the tumor
microenvironment and we also found that
those cells had a higher functional
quality there were more cytokine
production and activation of T cells in
the tumor Mark environment after we gave
this combination therapy
importantly we assessed the role of
innate immune sensing Pathways such as
type 1 interferons
the tlr pathways including my d88 and
other tlr signaling Pathways and sting
and other innate immune sensing
molecules inside the tumor
microenvironment
contrary to what was published at the
time we found that none of these enamine
sensing pathways are required for the
generation of this T Cell response
showing that cd40 was really able to
drive a unique Tesla response in the
tumor micro environment we also found as
we predicted that bad F3 dendritic cells
were required for cd40 advocacy as was
interfering gamma
importantly we found that when we gave
agonistic cd40 we drove a cd8
infiltration into the tumor site here
I'm showing a control tumor uh a mouse
from the control group that didn't
receive any therapy there's no T Cell
infiltration into the tumor site but
when we looked after therapy we could
see a robust infiltration of T cells
into the tumor
knowing that we had driven T cells into
the tumor site we hypothesized that if
we now added in immune checkpoint
blockade because we had that pool of
effector T cells we may actually see an
improved immune response using Agonist
agonistic cd40 with chemotherapy and
dualamine checked on blockade so here's
the treatment schema that I showed you
before and you can see that we have as I
showed you before our response with
chemotherapy in cd40 and now we did the
same treatment schema except we added in
anti-pd1 and anti-cla4 together ICB
immune checkpoint blockade
um concurrent with our treatment with
chemotherapy and agonistics 8040 and we
gave multiple doses of our immune
checkpoint therapy
when we did this you can see now in the
purple line that the mice responded very
well to this combination agonistic cd40
and immune checkpoint blockade with
archemotherapy in the green line is
similar to what I'm showing you on the
other side of the slide are cd40 with
chemotherapy and you can see survival is
extended but it's not as striking as
when we're giving this combination with
immune checkpoint Therapies
we wanted to translate some of these
findings into the clinical setting um
and so we partnered with stand up to
cancer CIT and cancion and Roche to do a
phase one neoadjuvant Advent trial so in
this clinical trial patients were
segregated either into arm one which got
anti-cd-40 or cellucellumab alone in the
neoadjuvant setting or arm2 where they
got a combination of donecitibine in
that paclotoxal with solutely map which
is agonistics 8040
and patients received a single dose of
agonistic cd40 with or without the
addition of the chemotherapy followed by
tumor resection at day 15. and then they
underlined recovery and then all
patients under one adjuvant chemotherapy
and Agonist of cd40 after surgery
and we were able to analyze a number of
different metrics but importantly for
this talk I'm going to focus on the
biological correlates specifically
within the tumor microenvironment to
understand the impact of using agonistic
cd40 in patient tumors
so in order to do this we partnered with
Lisa cousins at OHSU to use her
Multiplex IHC platform to understand
what's happening really within the tumor
microenvironment
so here Lisa's lab has developed a
multiplex system where she can stain for
a number of different markers within the
tumor microenvironment in an iterative
staining process and then in that single
slide we can assess where each of these
different markers is expressed and you
can see here by using this detailed
panel of immune markers we're able to
identify a number of different immune
and tumor microenvironment cell
populations as well as several
phenotypes as well as cell functions on
these cell populations and we can do
this in a very detailed manner across a
number of different samples and this
will allow us to understand what is
happening in the tumor microenvironment
after we're giving agonistic cd40.
so importantly in this study we did not
have a baseline biopsy from these tumors
so instead we took advantage of Lisa's
group
um creating a pancreatic tumor Atlas
where they had a large population of
patients that received either no
treatment before tumor resection or
chemo king of radiation and we were able
to use the exact same panel in those
patients and then compare it to the
patients that received agonistic cd40 to
understand if there were any differences
in our untreated tumors versus those
foreign
so here I'm showing major cell
populations that we identified in the
tumor microenvironment on the y-axis and
then our different patient samples are
shown here on the x-axis and this is
done by an unsupervised clustering we
found that the tumor microenvironments
clustered into three main phenotypes a
granulocytic rich microenvironment a T
cell-rich microenvironment and A myeloid
Rich tumor microenvironment
importantly you can see that here in the
black bars are patients that received
agonistic cd40 and you can see the
majority of them actually cluster into
this T cell-rich tumor microenvironment
cohort meaning that patients that were
treated with agonistic cd40 again which
is called cellucellumab had an 82 chance
of falling into this T cell Rich
phenotype whereas patients that received
either no treatment or received only
chemotherapy or chemo radiation therapy
in the neoadavin setting had only
between a 23 and a 37 percent chance of
falling into that tesol rich category so
again 9 out of our 11 patients that
receive the agonistics 8040 ended up
having a phenotype in the tumor marker
environment that appeared to be enriched
for T cells really suggesting that cd40
was altering the tumor microenvironment
in favor of T Cell infiltration into the
tumor site
we were further able to dig deeper into
this data by taking advantage of Lisa's
system to break the tumor into a number
of different regions in using
pathological annotations that identify
the tumor and the tumor border
the team segregated the tumors into
three different parts uh four different
parts sorry across the tissue slide so
there's the inter-tumeral which is
really the tumor Nest where the tumor
cells are all located followed by a
border region that's slightly farther
away from this edge of the tumor then we
have a spanning region that covers 50 50
the Border region and then this distal
region and this allows us to really
understand what's happening across the
entire tumor microenvironment and the
adjacent tissue that should be separate
from what's actually happening in the
tumor site theoretically this allows us
to really understand the difference
between what's happening right inside
the humor Ness and across the entire
tissue type
importantly here we're showing different
cell populations in different colors you
can see here on the y-axis it's showing
which cell population is being shown so
for example up top in these patients
from our treatment naive group you can
see the B cell population is shown in
Orange followed by our city T Cell
population in red and then the CD4
population is shown here in blue
and you can see also the relative
density of those cells by showing how
thick the line is so you can see B cells
are highly present for example at the
border of the tumor and inside of the
tumor Nest followed by cd8s being highly
present in those tumor sites
um where cd8s are more abundant when
we're looking also in the spanning
region so
um away from the exact border and tumor
microenvironment CD it's become more
enriched in these treatment-aid patients
so by doing this you can kind of imagine
the differences in the densities across
the entire tumor microenvironment and
again we can compare these Trends in
treatment naive patients to patients
that receive the agonistic cd-40
so here I'm showing our treatment naive
patients followed by our patients that
receive chemotherapy or chemo radiation
in the neoadjuvant setting and you can
see that there are some
similarities between the two groups
notably B cells or highly abundant
population in these two patient cohorts
um on the right side of the slide we
have our patients that receive the
agonistic cd40 in the new adjuvant
setting either with or without the
addition of chemotherapy and here
importantly you can see that T cells
have now become the most abundant immune
cell population present from the distal
site in the slide all the way into the
intertuminal region both cd4s and cd8s
have become a highly abundant cell
population that's present within the
tumor microenvironment so you can see
that both
cd4s shown in the light blue and cd8s
are present in increasing frequencies
and remain the dominant population
within the tumor microenvironment itself
so cd40 is not only increasing T Cell
infiltration into the tumor site but
it's also changing the spatial
distribution of immune cells all across
the tumor microenvironment within the
tumor nest and distal to the tumor as
well
we also looked in the peripheral blood
of these patients we wanted to
understand if there was systemic immune
activation occurring as we might expect
from giving agonistic cd40 so here I'm
showing on the left side of the slide
are CD4 effector cell population and on
the right side are CDA T Cell Factor
population we looked at a number of
different activation and potential
exhaustion markers and we found that
almost all of these were increased in
cd4s and cdas we also saw in cd8
specifically that there is an increase
in ki-67 suggestion an increase in
proliferation of these T cells
um instead of viewing this as exhaustion
we actually took this to me that we were
getting this priming of a T-cell
response systemically and that those T
cells were likely then infiltrating into
the tumor site
um and I will just mention that this
peripheral blood sample was taken at day
eight after agonistic cd40.
um so this is uh halfway in between the
treatment with cd40 and when the patient
went in for tumor resection so it's
about
um
about when we would expect to see an
increase in T Cell Activation in the
periphery after treatment with agonistic
City 40 that should drive to
self-harming
so just to conclude on this first part
we found that actually pancreatic cancer
is sensitive to immunity to destruction
and the KPC Mouse model we found that
both cd4s and cd8s are mediating this
destruction and importantly the
agonistic cd40 was able to bypass any
immune sensor stimulation and this
suggests to us that actually agonistics
8040 could be paired with other partners
but also that it's using a non-canonical
pathway to drive this activation which
opens the opportunity to use cd40 where
other immunotherapies have failed we
also found that cd40 agonism was
altering Tucson filtration into the
tumor microenvironment both in mice and
in patients and then cd40 was driving a
systemic T Cell Activation
so when we think back to our key
questions uh we determined that Yes
actually therapeutically enhancing
T-cell priming was driving tumor
immunity and we were able to identify a
number of different factors that
correlated with response to this
treatment
this actually led to another question as
you may have noticed there were some
slight differences in the patients
whether or not they had cd40 plus
chemotherapy and around this time I had
a master's student join in my group who
was very interested in understanding
what the potential impact of
chemotherapy was on the developing
immunotherapy induced response in some
cases we know that chemotherapy can
drive immunogenic tumor cell death and
could actually enhance T Cell responses
against tumors but in other cases we
know that chemotherapy can actually
drive the death of the tumor the immune
cells themselves because they are
proliferating after immune intervention
and we didn't know exactly what was
happening here
so to address this question we set up a
study similar to what I showed you
before where we gave mice agonistic cd40
and dual immune checkpoint blockade with
chemotherapy except at this time we also
set up an identical cohort of mice that
just received agonistic cd40 and
immunother and immune chocolate blockade
no chemotherapy so here I'm showing you
a waterfall plot where each bar is an
individual Mouse and you can see that in
the primary tumor response the waterfall
plots between our chemotherapy cd40 ICB
treated mice were almost identical to
mice that did not receive chemotherapy
and tumor growth control also looked
nearly identical but importantly when we
follow these mice long term we found
that the mice that received agonistic
cd40 and immune checkpoint blockade with
the addition of chemotherapy actually
slowly succumbs to tumor burden over
time so these tumors eventually grew out
and it suggested to us that the quality
of the T Cell response in these mindset
had chemotherapy was actually diminished
compared to the mice that did not
receive any chemotherapy
but we were also surprised to see that
we actually had a really good response
against a tumor in the absence of
chemotherapy and it suggested to us also
that cd40 and immune checkpoint therapy
was potent enough to drive a very robust
T Cell response against a tumor so we
wanted to interrogate this a little bit
further
so we first wanted to understand what
was required to generate this immune
response against a tumor did you need
both immune chocolate blockades or just
one
so here I'm showing the subcutaneous
tumor model that we use where we implant
our KPC cell line under the skin of the
mice the barrier here to generating T
Cell response is actually somewhat lower
than in other sites on the mice and you
can see here that actually the immune
response is pretty good if you use
agonistic cd40 with either pd1 or ctla4
or both
however when we did this in the more
aggressive orthotopic model where we
implant the tumor cells back into the
pancreas itself here it was very clear
that you needed to have both anti-pd1
and anti-acetyla4 on board in order to
get good tumor control
we also were interested in understanding
the sequencing we had used previous
sequencing models to predict that we
needed cd40 after chemotherapy and so
here we modeled giving agonistic cd40
first and then giving immune checkpoint
blockade instead of our traditional
route where we gave immune checkbook
blockade first and then agonistic cd40
and you can see that the original plan
where we gave anti-pd1 and c2a4 followed
three days later by agonistic cd40
actually did slightly better than when
we gave cd40 first and then suggested to
us that there may be some impact of
combining cd40 and immune checkpoint
blockade during the priming phase we
needed to have immune checkpoint
blockade on board at the same time
so we next went to look at the induced
immune response to determine if both
cd4s and cd8s were required and we found
that during the primary phase both were
actually contributing to the immune
response so depletion of either cd4s or
cd8 is completely uh abrogated our
therapeutic effect
however we were surprised to find that
in the memory phase if we depleted CDA T
cells the mice actually rejected the
tumors just fine cd8s were not required
for rejection of secondary tumors
instead we found that cd4s were actually
critical for this memory response so if
we depleted our CD4 cells we completely
lost the therapeutic benefit
we went on to check for systemic T Cell
Activation similar to what we had
observed in patients we found that in
mice looking between day seven and day
10 especially in the peripheral blood we
saw an increased activation of CD4 T
cells in circulation and you can see
here we measured this by both cd44
positive cd60 to a low phenotype as well
as like cd11a expression I mean you can
see right at day 10 we have this peak of
T cells in the periphery that diminishes
slightly and we know that that's
actually because that's the time point
at which the CD4 T cells are actually
trafficking to the tumor which I'm
showing over on the right hand side of
the slide
we found that cd40 was critical for this
increased systemic T Cell Activation and
we found this also in the tumor draining
lymph node immune chalkland blockade was
not contributing at all to the systemic
diesel activation but instead this was
solely mediated by agonistic cd4d and
I'm not showing it here but we found
that the addition of immune checkpoint
blockade was really obvious when we
looked in the tumor microenvironment and
found that only when you had both immune
checkpoint blockade and cd40 together
did you see an increased capacity for
cytokine production including cells able
to produce multiple different cytokines
here we're showing that we found a CD4 T
cells trafficked into the tumor site
through the ccl5 ccr5 access so we found
that if we blocked ccl5 after therapy we
had a significant reduction in the
proportion of T cells able to traffic
into the tumor site and that was
mediated by CD4 T cells so if you block
ccl5 you didn't see any reduction in CDA
T cells it was just C4 T cells that were
used in this pathway
and if we used CD4 T cells that lacked
ccr5 expression they were unable to
traffic into the tumor site to the same
extent that wild type cells transferred
in were able to so cd40 is activating T
cells specifically it's activating CD4 T
cells to traffic into the tumor site
through ccr5 and that's critical for
tumor rejection in this model
so just for some final thoughts here we
found that t-stone filtration into the
tumor site is actually crucial for
successful immunotherapy CD4 T cells
seem to be the major population that's
trafficking in but we know that CDA T
cells are also required in the memory
phase
we found that uh sorry in the priming
phase we found that T Cell priming
requires agonistic cd40 we've been
unable to generate really robust T Cell
responses against this tumor in the
absence of agonistic cd40 and that uh to
our surprise chemotherapy is actually
detrimental to this developing immune
response against the tumor
this suggests that we need to revisit
our sequencing and scheduling of
chemotherapy and immunotherapy not just
in pancreatic cancer but likely in many
different tumors and we think there's
opportunity to continue to use
chemotherapy and then consider adding in
immunotherapy during a maintenance phase
or when patients progress or no longer
want to be on chemotherapy and they
think that the mouse model will provide
a way for us to continue to address this
important question and finally I think
uh we the field need to think more about
how to harness CD4 T cells in the tumor
microenvironment I think that pancreatic
cancer at least in this system is giving
us a window and the potential of cd4s
and being potent tumor rejectors and we
think we have the opportunity to address
that question even further in the future
so with that I would just like to
acknowledge my current University where
I have a team that's carrying on with a
number of these studies especially with
regard to the CD4 T-cell response
um and much of this work was actually
done at Penn where I was before I moved
to OHSU
um the last part of the talk was done by
Alex Morrison who was a master's student
in my lab and is now a resident at
University of Pennsylvania
much of this work was done in
collaboration with Bob Bonner Heights
group Ben Stinger's group also had
collaborations with John Barry's lab and
some of the clinical data that I showed
was done in collaboration with Rosie
Mick at Penn as well as Courtney Betts
from Lisa cousins lab with support from
Sam from her lab as well
um I have my email address listed here
and I'm happy to take any questions over
email or through the chat function here
as needed thank you